nous voulons rendre l'application de la loi plus forte et
non plus faible nous ne rembourserons jamais la
police
nous embaucherons plus de bons
policiers je pense que nous devons financer la
police et trouver d'autres moyens communautaires d'
apporter un soutien
aux situations qui n'ont pas besoin d'être
aggravées  que la façon dont ils sont
[Musique]
c'est un plaisir juste de pouvoir avoir
la chance de les rencontrer quand nous
avons cette opportunité aussi
je suis juste reconnaissant pour ce qui se passe
et nous ne déchargerons tout simplement pas pour notre
acte de police  à passer à l'
avenir  quand ils font cela, alors
absolument rien n'a été
réalisé ou atteint en définissant la
police la raison numéro un pour laquelle la criminalité
continue d'augmenter
est à cause des politiciens les politiciens
continuent de faire tout ce qu'ils peuvent
pour affaiblir le système à m  rendre le public
plus heureux et c'est juste parce que le
public est tout simplement ignorant en ce qui concerne
la relation entre les criminels et
[Musique] la
police
[Musique]
donc
vous